hello guys and welcome back to
jaegerists in today's video we'll be
going through the story of flock
forester the demon's assistant
during the feast before the expedition
to shiganshiman district fluk
rhetorically asks gene kirsten if 104th
recruits and former garrison members
such as himself and his friend are that
unreliable when gene asks why he and his
friends joined the survey corps flock
says the increased propaganda for the
survey corps after the uprising is what
drew them in
he notes how much the 104th soldiers
have changed since they had graduated
during the operation to retake
shiganshinan district flock and the rest
of the recruits enter shiganshina on
foot while the rest of the soldiers use
their vertical maneuvering equipment to
make their way to the top of the wall
they're ambushed by the beast titan who
appears with an army of titans and
throws a boulder into the side of wall
maria causing a collapse that blocks the
survey core's entrance sushiganshina
leaving flock and the other soldiers
unable to enter with their horses flock
and his squad mates are left in charge
of the core's horses and are ordered to
defend them from an approaching titans
the beast titan begins to target his
throws at the soldiers themselves and
levi orders the recruits to take the
horses closer to the wall where they can
use boulders for cover flock begins to
panic and levi has to force him along
the base of the wall marlow scolds him
for letting some of their horses run
away in the attack but flock
hysterically retorts that there's no
point to watching the horses since they
will all soon die
recalling the ceremony where he decided
to join the survey corps flock laments
that he's going to die a meaningless
death rather than bravely sacrifice
himself for humanity when erwin smith
gives his plans of a suicide charge
against the beast titan to the recruits
flock protests that they have no reason
to participate in the charge since they
will die either way despite his protests
flock and his comrades are won over by
irwin's urging that they fight for the
good of humanity so that the living can
give meaning to their deaths
during the charge flock is knocked off
of his horse but miraculously managed to
survive shocked by his survival flock
begins to wander the battlefield
searching for anyone else who may have
survived after finding erwin wounded and
bleeding on the battlefield flock treats
the commander's wounds as best he can
before pursuing captain levi as levi
prepares to give aaron jaeger the titan
injection needed to heal armin arlord he
arrives with irwin hanging unconscious
on his back while the others begin to
argue over who should receive the serum
flock gives his opinion that erwin
should be the one to receive the serum
as only a demon like erwin can overcome
the titans aaron tries to dissuade levi
from giving irwin the serum but flock
forcibly restrains him to stop him from
interfering
levi orders that he be left alone to
inject irwin and flock forcibly moves
aaron to another house rooftop after
armin is given a serum instead of erwin
flock is left dismayed and asks levi why
he chose armin over irwin
on top of shiganshina district's wall
flock keeps watch and observes the
surrounding area as aaron informs armin
about the events which ensued from the
battle as the remaining members of the
survey corps prepare for a ceremony in
their honor they're approached by hitch
who has come to watch the ceremony jean
assures her that marlowe acted bravely
on their mission and asks flock to
recount the events to her although flock
praises marlow for staying calm and
encouraging his fellow recruits he
admits that marlow likely regretted his
actions in his final moments as hitch
leaves a nepal gene demands to know why
flock says such a thing to hitch and
flock tells him that someone should be
honest about what happened armin admits
that he knows flock wanted irwin to live
and flock claims that everyone who has
read the corpse report believes irwin
should have lived aaron tries to defend
armin but flock accuses him of acting
childishly and allowing his personal
feelings to keep him from making a
rational choice jean and connie
intervene before things can escalate
further but flock reprimands them as
well pointing out that they made no
effort to stop aaron and mikasa flock
closes by demanding that they inform any
future recruits of what they are truly
signing up for so that no more cowards
like him join with the arrival of the
anti-marlian volunteers flock brings
yelena and aaron in contact so she could
explain zeke's true motives to euthanize
the eldian race sometime after the
meeting with elena aaron meets with
flock privately and states that he is
going to follow zeke in appearance only
asking him to do the same flock
questions aaron about his true
intentions and aaron reveals that he
will use the founding titan's power to
bring ruin to the world flock agrees
with aaron and begins gathering allies
forming a secret faction that would
later be known as the jaegers
approximately nine months later flock
joins the survey corps at the raid on
liberio where he sets explosives to
destroy buildings around the
intermittent zone gene yells at him to
minimize civilian casualties but flock
is unrepentant he tells gene of all of
the people inside the walls who were
killed by the people outside of it when
gene argues with him flock points to
aaron it reminds jean that aaron told
them to fight rather than wait within
the walls for death to find them
declaring that aaron is the devil that
they need
some time after flock is forced to take
cover from the beast titans bombardment
as the survey corps makes its retreat
from liberio flock leads the surviving
soldiers in a celebration of their
overwhelming victory against marley as
they're celebrating two children board
the corps airship and opened fire
killing sasha blaus in response flock
and his fellow soldiers attacked the
children savagely apprehending and
disarming them flock asks gene if he
should throw them out of the airship but
is denied unhappy with aaron's arrest
following their return to parody flock
and several other survey corps recruits
leaked news of aaron's confinement to
the public which puts pressure on hanji
to release him they're quickly
discovered and are called before hanji
to explain themselves flock argues that
aaron was justified in his actions and
that his actions have saved the lives of
the citizens of parody hanchi points out
that aaron's actions have only demonized
them to the rest of the world but flock
insists that they have nothing to worry
about as long as aaron has the power of
the founding titan rather than freeing
aaron hanji concludes the hearings by
arresting flock and his compatriots
flakken's companions are quickly freed
by other members of the military who've
sided with aaron and the group makes a
plan to meet up with aaron outside of
the city after aaron escapes his cell
and arrives flock informs him of their
numbers along with their involvement in
zachary's assassination flock claims
only aaron can save the eldian empire
and aaron tells the group he will locate
zeke
after being informed of hanji's location
by a sympathetic employee
flock joins the other jaegers in raiding
a restaurant the faction threatens hanji
and their subordinates with firearms and
flock demands that they take them to
sikh's location in hanji's query he
reveals to them that aaron refuses to
negotiate with the military hanji tries
to reason with flock arguing that they
do not have time to be infighting while
zeke is making his own moves but their
words fall on deaf ears and flock orders
that they be restrained hanji deduces
that flock was aware of the spinal fluid
scheme but flock refuses to give an
answer only ordering hanji to remain
quiet when the captains are directed out
flock taps on the door to inform aaron
that they are leaving arriving in
shiganchina flock immediately leads the
jaegers to the division of the training
corps operating out of the district he
and the jaegers inform instructor keith
shadas and the recruits that the jaegers
will now be operating out of the
training corps base shooting off a
warning shot when keith attempts to
resist flock invites all of the
assembled recruits to join the yeagers
and abandon all of their old customs
from before they learned of the outside
world as recruits begin to join him
flock informs them that they will have
to prove their loyalty by beating keith
and that anyone who doesn't will be
thrown in jail after the recruits have
finished beating keith flock orders
hanji to take him to zeke flock and the
jaegers with him learn that zeke is in
the custody of levi and 30 members of
the survey corps still loyal to the
military and route to their location
flock hears a sound resembling thunder
near the edge of the forest they go to
investigate and find a completely
destroyed wagon along with an injured
soldier lying on their bank of the river
flock expresses its initial worry about
levi being a problem but is pleased to
see he will not be a concern due to his
injuries after hearing hanji claim that
levi is dead flock is not fully
convinced and orders hanji to move so he
can check for a pulse however before he
can he and the other soldiers are
suddenly distracted by the sight of zeke
emerging from inside a decomposing titan
this gives hanji the opportunity to flee
with levi's body catching flock off
guard while other jaegers leave to
pursue them flock then tries to get zeke
to explain what happened but zeke
brushes him off claiming that they need
to move on flock and his soldiers arrive
with zeke as shiganshina to find it
under attack by marley's forces while
zeke pummels marley's titans with rocks
from atop the wall flock takes his group
to kill the car titan and keep it from
using its artillery to hurt zeke they
seemingly manage to take the titan down
but are caught off guard when marley and
soldiers appear from the car titan's
corpse and begin firing on them forcing
them to retreat flock and the soldiers
continue to attack the car titan but are
quickly repelled with everyone except
for flock being killed as flock
confronts the worsening situation aaron
makes contact with zeke and starts the
rumbling as flock watches the wall begin
to crumble beneath him after all of
zeke's pure titans are killed he meets
with the survivors at the headquarters
he talks with jean expressing that he
could not die during the moment of the
aldean empire's return flock then points
his gun at yelena and demands her to
gather the anti-marlin volunteers so
they can be detained one of the
volunteers tries resisting and flock
wounds the man by shooting him in the
hand flock informs the volunteers that
he's known about aaron's plan to unlock
the founding titan for 10 months he
acknowledges that the volunteer's
respective homelands will indeed be
destroyed by aaron's plan and offers to
grant them status as honorary aldeans in
the new empire aaron will create if they
agree to cooperate the injured volunteer
continues to belittle flock who responds
by nonchalantly executing him as the
volunteers are led away flock claims to
gene and mikasa that as aaron's
representative he's trying to wipe out
any resentment in parody in an attempt
to gain gene's support flock makes an
appeal to gene's old desire to live a
comfortable life as an mp
mikasa demands to know what happened to
levi and hanji and flock claims that
zeke killed them in the following days
on yankampon and yelena continued to
resist flock's invitation to join the
gagarists as honorary aldeans so he
decides to have them publicly executed
flock and gene brings the two volunteers
before the jagerists and flock announces
their execution explaining that yelena
conspired with zeke to destroy the
aldians and that onyankapon had chosen
death over joining jaegerists
jean fires four shots at nyoyankapon and
misses all of them and to flock shock
the car titan suddenly attacks eating
gene onyankapon and yelana flock takes a
group of jaegerists to paradise harbor
to confront the azumabito clan and force
their mechanics to cooperate with them
after executing three of kiyomi's
companions he gloats about aaron's
impending success and cheerfully reminds
them that hizuru will also be wiped out
he attempts to coerce her into agreeing
to help the yeagers but kyomi only
reminds him that the eldians will keep
killing each other even after the
outside world is destroyed flock
disregards her warning and threatens to
kill her admitting that he's willing to
sacrifice parody's technological
advancement to eliminate potential
enemies he's interrupted by connie and
armin arriving at the harbor explaining
that they need the azumabito mechanics
to pilot their airship so that they can
pursue the car titan suspecting that the
two are lying flock decides to execute
the azumabito mechanics to keep them
from posing a threat in the future
however he's caught off guard and
disarmed by kiyomi before phlox comrades
can help him mikasa bursts into the
building and incapacitates them as well
with no one to help flock flees the
building and announces to the rest of
the yeagers that they are under attack
as the jaegerists attack flock becomes
uneasy that mikasa and the azumabito
have fled to the basement as the armored
and female titans transform flock
realizes that they have been led into a
trap and turns his attention to fighting
off the titans during the battle the
azumabitos attempt to reach the boat and
flock realizing that they intend to take
the boat frantically orders his soldiers
to target them when the car titan
appears flock tries to target her
himself but is caught off guard by the
emergence of the jaw titan while his
soldiers are killed flock manages to
escape the jaw titan and targets the
boat attempting to sink it with the
thunderspear while saying that he will
be the savior of el dia however as he's
firing he is shot by gabby braun
throwing off his aim and causing him to
plummet injured into the ocean despite
his injuries flock manages to attach his
maneuvering gears anchors to the boat
and follows the group across the ocean
to odiha badly injured flock is able to
drag himself into the hangar where the
azumabito mechanics are preparing the
flying boat for takeoff and begins
firing on them he manages to hit the
boat's fuel tank but mikasa quickly
fires one of her anchors into his throat
as the mechanics attempt to fix the boat
flock uses his last breath to beg hanji
and gene to stop pursuing aaron citing
that his rumbling though immoral was
paradise's only hope for survival
thank you guys so much for watching this
video it really means a lot to us we'll
see you guys very soon in one of our
next videos